oh my gosh destroyed this is your house
shut that guy oh we say okay then you
have six we just had to leave the
building because there was an aftershock
so everyone who was inside had to come
back out you can see the concern is
obvious on the streets right now they
don't want these buildings to keep
shaking they're worried about even more
aftershocks that was in the middle of
the aftermath of the deadliest natural
disaster in the history of the Western
Hemisphere the earthquake that struck
Haiti ten years ago this weekend killed
an estimated 250,000 people and injured
far more billions of dollars poured in
to help
despite that little has changed in fact
much of Haiti is worse off than it was a
decade ago but there is one very bright
spot that could provide a path for the
future as we discovered on our visits
this week our trip began in the capital
port-au-prince in the wake of Haiti's
worst year since the earthquake mass
protests gang violence rampant political
corruption jobs are scarce but perhaps
most tragically basic medical care can
be almost impossible to find so this is
the general hospital in port-au-prince
or at least it should be the hospital
after the earthquake decimated the old
hospital a new one was planned
immediately after more than 80 million
has been spent on it it sits empty today
in the meantime the old General Hospital
what should be the main source of care
for Hades biggest city reeks of raw
sewage piles of trash are everywhere
that noise on the air and her four month
old son have been here for eight days
[Music]
yes to go he can't go to the bathroom
sorry I can't imagine the pain that he's
in right many patients don't get treated
because they're often required to
provide the medical supplies something
as simple as surgical gloves that the
hospital can't afford but take a trip
outside the capital and you find a
remarkable place that many doubted could
ever exist in this country this is st.
Boniface Hospital in Fond du Blanc up
the mountains on Haiti's southern
peninsula it was started in 1983 and in
the last 10 years has become a leading
beacon for Haitian hope people come from
hours away to this hospital and it could
be anything the emergency room maternity
anything Conor Shapiro is the president
of health equity International which
oversees st. Boniface he first came here
in 2003 and his wife is Haitian on the
day the earthquake struck he was at work
massive shaking all the patients came
running out of the hospital all the
staff everyone was running into the yard
we didn't know what had happened my wife
was pregnant with our now nine-year-old
was in port-au-prince at the time and I
didn't know what was going on I can only
imagine what that was like I was very
fortunate my wife and our daughter they
survived and many people were not as
fortunate it was a horrible situation
instead of falling apart
Boniface has only grown they now get
five hundred patients a day and went
from an annual operating budget of two
hundred and fifty thousand dollars when
Shapiro took over to eight million today
people risk their lives to get here
because they have no other choice this
is the entrance road to the hospital it
is full of ruts it is mountainous
passable only by dirt bikes like this
and 4x4 vehicles these bikes effectively
act
as ambulances for people who need care
the drive up that treacherous road takes
the better part of an hour that's in
addition to the three or four hours it
can take just to get to the entrance
this woman is nine months pregnant and
could deliver at any moment I can okay
we have patients coming all day it's a
constant flow of patients for more than
two million people on the southern
peninsula this is the only place to get
an emergency c-section the only place
with a neonatal intensive care unit we
have 35 babies here over 95% of these
babies were born here at the hospital in
the maternity center if this unit
weren't here what would happen to these
kids and what percent of them who are
here survive right now we've been able
to make it so that 85% of the babies
here surviving st. boniface has become
one of the primary teaching hospitals in
all of Haiti
it houses the spinal cord trauma center
that treated many of the people injured
in the earthquake I think what's great
is we're not treating most of those
spinal cord injured patients who came
from the earthquake and the reason is
they're back home living their lives
they've learned how to become productive
members of society despite their
handicap we've been able to reach our
goal of reintegrating them and allowing
them to go back to being full productive
members of society
that could not be more true for Mac Sony
persona every morning he wheels himself
up the hill to work at st. Boniface
helping people just as they helped him
persona was trapped under rubble for
three days after the earthquake when he
was pulled out he was told he would
never walk again where would you be if
it weren't for this place
maybe that [ __ ] tunnel owie wasn't them
the cash inequality I don't know maybe
I'd be in the street maybe I'd find
someplace to live I don't know where I'd
be very likely might not be alive we
exact demonically st. Boniface does not
turn any patients away they also
received no money from the Haitian
government they survive in a mix of
private donations and outside grants
doctor inna Baer Pierre is in charge of
running the hospital on a daily basis
he's been at Saint Boniface for 18 years
I think we inspire people and that's why
also teaching has been more and more
part of what we do here because we want
to inspire a new model in the Haitian
healthcare system and with not tons of
finances there ways to improve
healthcare system with some commitment
accountability and hard work we asked
Conor Shapiro why Boniface has succeeded
when so many others have failed there's
no magic potion here it's just been this
slow successful bill but that has been
given time yes absolutely
the community here has been the leader
of this project from the beginning
they're the ones now working here at the
hospital really it's about investing in
the Haitian people in the physicians the
health practitioners and nurses lab
techs who are here already and we need
to invest in them to be able to provide
that care there are lots of excuses for
why things can go wrong in Haiti we just
don't accept any of them because we know
that this is the right thing to do
lots of excuses for why things can go
wrong we just don't accept any of them
Jeff that the first baby that you showed
and the turmoil of that baby and then
you juxtapose it with what the hospital
is able to do this
is incredible absolutely incredible that
there's at least one place one beacon of
hope and imagine the heartbreak of that
mom who shows up with her child who's
been screaming crying is in such pain
and she says you can't we can't treat
you because you don't have a dollar for
surgical gloves and all the doctors and
nurses and staff that are on board who
are Haitian who are working so hard to
ensure that that hospital is every still
there every single person who works at
Saint Boniface is Haitian that's they've
they made this concerted and vigilant
and determined effort to make sure they
build from within and they listen to the
community and that's why it works
whenever there's a tragedy people give
money right away and in this case you
see money that is actually working
that's right at this hospital
you